[Musique]
m'appelle tout le bourg
su paysans jeu producteurs de l'aisne
et la vie devient de plus en plus dur il
faut le lire
mais je ne me plierai pas pour par
exemple pour aller travailler à l'usiné
je m'y adapte au rapport
[Musique]
je m'appelle legris albert j'ai 43 ans
j'ai été obligé de quitter la terre pour
aller travailler en usine
mais
pendant trois ans mais j'ai pas pu m'y
adapter j'étais obligé de revenir la
terre
à bonneville la louvet dans le calvados
à 30 km de deauville l'obsession des
petits paysans celle usine bonneville
670 habitants de 1000 hectares d'herbes
âgées de pommiers 52 ferme alors qu'il y
en avait le double voilà vingt ans c'est
qu'en normandie que l'on dise est riche
l'agriculture n'est plus rentable si
l'on ne possède pas 50 hectares et
bonneville la louvet est un village de
paysans comme beaucoup d'autres qui va
devenir sous peu un dortoir d'ouvriers
déjà bien des fermes ne sont plus que
des logements les hommes ont abandonné
la terre pour aller travailler en usine
il y a deux en un seul quart partaient
chaque jour pour les usines du havre
distante de 70 km aujourd'hui il y en a
deux qui transportent 60 passagers 60
paysans ouvriers qui viennent de
bonneville de blangy des authieux de
cormeilles qui abandonne l'indépendance
d'autrefois pour la sécurité d'un
salaire d'os 12 100 francs par mois
je m'appelle robert nous
j'ai 42 ans
j'ai été paysan
je n'ai pas pu rester à la terre
pour moi ce n'était plus rentable
maintenant je travaille à l'usiné
le métier de lusine c'est pas mon métier
d'abord ainsi on avait la possibilité de
rester inculture bon d'accord je serais
ce que j'ai à faire
mais en usine
devenue un reg le rajout chef d'equipe
non jamais
c'était un peu dur le bruit enfermé
et puis ce qu'assène apprenait dans les
chambres
est enfermé jours l'allemagne était dû à
quoi dur c'est dur mais ainsi faire
couler chef une minute c'est une minute
vendredi
14h15 l'usiné renault de sandouville
[Musique]
faux
je
[Musique]
oui
jusqu'à une grande différence de
mentalité entre les gens dits dentition
milieux ouvriers et
les ouvriers qui viennent de milieux
paysans pas tellement non mais
de platon pour eux c'est une chance de
pouvoir retrouver un travail et c'est
une chance inespérée par conséquent ils
font le maximum pour pouvoir réussir
dans ce qu'on peut dire sur cyclage tous
ses postes de travail sont étudiées je
joins des postes de capacité moyenne
donc tout le monde après une période
d'adaptation de 15 jours pelé peut les
tenir et faire le travail correctement
comme il peut ne pas te fais dans les
ans les jambes nous avons les africains
nous recevons des africains qui n'ont
jamais travaillé en usine et ces gens là
au bout de quinze jours arrivent à faire
le travail correctement par conséquent
pour un européen doit pas y avoir de
problème il n'y en a pas alors il
[Musique]
sur nous combien de temps vous a donné
pour vous pour apprendre ce travail
après dix ans passés à la ferme
environ 3,1
franz mann il a fallu que vous aurez
appreniez à travailler différemment pour
passer votre vie oui ça a été difficile
au début ça très limité qu'est ce que
vous pensez du fait que votre mari est
abandonné sa vie de paysan pour aller
travailler à l'usiné fans étaient venus
viger si ç'avait été autrement ça aurait
été mieux de rester pour les deux c'est
l'exploitation tu as fait et comme
vraiment c'est plus assez rentable il
est obligé
d'aller à l'usiné est obligée d'élever
les enfants tout ça il faut tenir et
vous l'avait encouragé à aller à l'usiné
bien oui fallait prendre une solution
pour arriver à seul
savons comment nous y avait pensé à
l'usiné mais on a dit ça sera un mois
assuré l'appel sera assurée on pourra
compter dessus c'est du certain poids
que les bêtes c'est pas certain qu'un
pas c'est un salaire certains points
c'est toujours le même homme massa oui
oui ça pas fait changer son caractère du
tout marc feu non non ça nous a remis
d'aplomb c'est dire le moins mettre
certains tout ça ça nous a redonné bon
moral
ce qui vous raconte ses histoires
d'ateliers zélie soral usines ce qui se
passe avec ses camarades oui quelques
fois une détient la journée s'est bien
passée où moi je lui demande
[Musique]
combien de temps vous avez été la terre
avant
j'étais ouvrir l'école à
14 ans et vous avez quel âge
je vais jusqu'à toi
[Musique]
ne vous sentez en forme pour toujours
depuis que vous êtes à l'usiné terre
depuis deux ans n'hésitez pas plus
fatigué qu'avant non jeu
j'ai bien pris lui envoyait un pays
vendredi 23h le retour vers bonneville
ses anciens paysans après une journée de
travail et les usines vont mettre une
heure pour rentrer dans leurs villages
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu garde
la peine à marcher nos lauriers non
c'est bon marché ait piqué et en ont
enlevé j'avais retenu les gens
retiennent maintenant j'ai enlevé au
moins
6,5
là aujourd'hui palais vers 550 pièces à
l'heure
non là ça va encore mais il ya des
fraîches les cadors que sont parfois
zale
rapport à ce que vous gagnez canton
était agriculteur je m'organise
maintenant l usine d une très grosse
différence
[Musique]
c'est pas comparable
en culture ce n'est pas vivable
je prends vival combien qui sont payés
en cuir le le temps
ben on pourrait baisser de ce mini car
il ya 400 à 410 da
et puis à pas d'heure malgré un espace à
un agriculteur à son compte comme il
peut se faire par mois
alors là
c'est que même qui gagne sa vie ça va
aller pendant un an et puis ce qui
attire casetti semaines avant de la
perdre la bataille là c'est mort
00h05 c'est le retour à bonneville
ya beaucoup de paysans qui quittent la
terre comme ça maintenant
beaucoup il y en a il ya beaucoup de
jeunes que je connais qui sont arrivés à
sandouville qui était dans la culture
avant ils ont quitté parce que c'était
vraiment pas intéressant vainqueur de
moi même des patrons cultivateurs
conquis
t128 30 hectares ils ont une petite et
la culture ils ont mieux aimer l'eau et
leur ferme est allé à l'usiné qu'est ce
que vous préférez un symbole cellule
usine où la ferme savoir si j'avais les
moyens de me payer de faire le moyenne
faire l'on craint qu'à rome une
quarantaine d'armes en fera certainement
sa allusion dans l'eau je suis chez
renault pour gagner ma vie c'est tout
c'est pour çà me plaisent tellement
de choses auxquelles on n'est pas
habitué dans l'agriculture savoir des
chefs
ont les cheveux
aussi faibli
mais obligé de s'y faire vite parce que
quand ils disent quelque chose on est
obligé de les suivre sans ça c'est la
porte twitter
il faut suivre la cadence sur laquelle m
samedi celle et renou
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire plus
tard de ce garçon allez encore un petit
peu trop jeune mais enfin
cette fois il fera plus tard c'est à
dire
je crois que la vie et changera d'ici là
oui on espère
jean claude
oui très bien
tu vois on profite du boîtier on profite
un peu de bouteille
hélas oui ça va quand même mon violet
rui 1 mais oui ça va tu veux prendre une
petite maison jaune à une bonne si tu
veux vous savez on boit beaucoup on
n'est pas les pires impôts pas l'oublier
le mal que je dis que j'aurais du mal à
me haddad adapté parce qu'elle est
doublement je peux pas travailler la
nuit si je bosse la nuit je ne peux pas
dormir dans jours alors il devient très
nerveux je suis obligé de prendre des
calmants 1 et puis de prendre des
calmants m'a fait du bien après plus
rien je tombe j'aimerais travailler en
usine à non à nora non alors là surtout
pas surtout pas la nuit elle même dans
la journée avec le raffut qui allaitent
dans un ton temps les matins pour
emboutir les lignes les pare chocs tout
pour miss a fait un raffut infernal non
façon j'ai bossé angibaud celle
prévalant dans la seine et oise est ce
que je le promets que jamais mieux faire
n'importe quel travail un même fait à la
vidange de n'importe quelle cochonnerie
d'aller bosser origine non ils croient
pas en toi non c'est la politique et
pour qui est deux ou trois exploitants
c'est tout toi qui sera le vacher où le
oui le serviteur de ces messieurs
directeur à son directeur il rappelle
que les jouets bien
travaillé en usine que de me laisser
commandé par un corps
chef de culture qui ne connaît
absolument rien d'absolument inique
romana choix la planète
sous peu de temps les agriculteurs ne
trouveront pas de femmes et ça c'est
prouvé parce que si un gars n'a pas de
situation la femme ni vis ni verra
jamais jamais à lire à trouver le gars
qui est salariée dans une gym qu'à une
paye d'assurer ma n'ira pas s'embêter
avec un dock apprennent à rome qu'ils
oublient femmes viennent toutes les
campagnes maintenant pour aller cela
vaut la peine car à ma femme que mangas
les frises et à ne pas payer le coiffeur
ni qu'ils se soient d'hier est pour la
peine de chercher là dedans tu apprends
du tout on peut alors quand une frise
apparaître propres tares vu un coup de
queue de vache bardé de bouche de vache
comme on dit chez nous le maire de bages
la femme si elle s'est fait de friser
par exemple hier va demain et toutes les
glaces
de terre au bout du compte
ce qui sont six privet retour est
on est habillé avec des habits gooden de
la ville que les gens veulent porter
toute cette scène insolite ailleurs son
arrêt pour les moyens j'estime une chose
que si on avait la main les moyens la
possibilité d'aller bouffer entre de
l'hôtel salak serait quand même ma femme
n'y a pas de problème à les apprentis
qui moment de respirer combattu vous
n'avez jamais jamais je mets à jamais on
n'a pas les moyens de se payer l'hôtel
pour mes mots resteront à jamais mais
non mais non papa le cinéma ce coup
d'oeil et quelquefois je vous dirais
qu'il ya
douzaine d'années j'ai prêté
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous aimez
ainsi donc ce que vous aimeriez vous et
moi ce que j'en à voir des films
vraiment naturel quoi ce qui se passe
dans la nature faune comme leur truc qui
nous proche du jour aujourd'hui je te
dis tout un tas de bourgeoise et tout le
fourbi tout ça ça m'intéresse pas qu'on
parle un peu de dans nos affaires
quoique on parle de la culture comme on
parle par exemple la vie d'un ouvrier
comme on parle tout un tas de choses
comme ça quoi ça doit jamais jamais
jamais
et dans la vie quel est ton quel est ton
plus grand plaisir alors là mon plus
grand plaisir le plus grand plaisir de
claude le bourg une boutade en guise de
rêve pouvoir une fois dans sa vie faire
au petit matin comme les entraîneurs des
haras normand une de ces longues
promenades sur les plages de deauville
qui affine si bien les jarrets des
pur-sang
l'hiver emmené mes vaches sur les
planches là bas sur la plage leur faire
prendre un bain de pieds
surtout push jarret chasse assez bon y'a
pas de problème ça c'est sain pour les
vaches un
sale et sort un peu de l'ordinaire dit
non parce qu'ils ont tellement les pieds
dans la merde de l'hiver tu comprends
quelques bons ballons pied quand les
parisiens sont plus là
leur fait prendre un bon bain et ça
c'est bon pour déjà rien
prenant bien
et c'est lundi le car pour lui zine est
à 12h50
[Musique]
je m'appelle robert renoue
j'ai 42 ans
j'ai été paysan
je n'ai pas pu rester à la terre
pour moi ce n'était plus rentable
maintenant je travaille à l'usiné
[Musique]